what are the conditions that a person
needs to have these Deeds accepted by
Allah subhah wa ta'ala the basic two
conditions are number one is the
intention it should only be for Allah
subhana wa ta'ala and no one else
whatever deed you do it should only be
for Allah subhana wa tala and no one
else this is very important if this
condition is not met then all your Deeds
are wasted and Allah subh says in the
Quran in Sur Bay chapter number
98 verse number five it says that you
worship none but Allah subhana wa ta'ala
and you do it only for him and for no
one
else it is further
mention in Surah insan chapter number 76
verse number n it
says that we have fed you for the sake
of Allah subhana wa tala for the
pleasure of Allah subhana tala we do not
require any reward from you nor do you
require any returns that means if you
feed someone it is for the sake of Allah
subhana tala not seeking a reward or not
seeking anything in return this is a
very important factor that we should
note all your actions should be for the
sake of Allah subhana T that's a very
important factor and further is
mentioned in the Quran in Surah sh
chapter number 42 verse number 20 that
if you do a deed for the Tilt for the
reward in the Hereafter Allah Allah
subhana wa ta'ala will multiply your
reward your tilt in the yearafter and if
you do a deed or any action for a reward
in this world Allah will give you the
reward in this world but you'll have no
share in the
Hereafter Allah repeated that message in
Surah HUD chapter number
11 verse number 15 and 16 that
anyone who seeks the reward in this
world or does any deed for this world
and for the glitter of this world Allah
subhana wa ta'ala will surely give him
in this world but he will have no share
in the Hereafter except fire except
hell and all his
deeds will not be useful in the
Hereafter so therefore whatever we do
should be for Allah subhana wa tala and
the second Cal of
Islam Omar please with him it's mention
say BK volume number oneith number one
may Allah be pleased with him he
said that the Beloved Prophet mallam
said which means your Deeds are judged
on your
intention and the prophet further said
that all your actions are based on your
intention and anyone who has
migrated for Allah and his rasool he has
migrated for Allah and
if anyone has an Hijra migrated for the
worldly benefits or for marriage he has
migrated for the worldly benefits and
marriage so ni is very important and
this is further
repeated in another Hadith in say Muslim
volume number four Hadith number
7114 it says that our beloved Prophet M
wasallam said that Allah subhana T says
that I am alone sufficient I do not not
require any associate and if anyone does
any deed for anyone else as well as for
me I
renounce that for the person who he has
Associated to that means you can't do
part of the deed for Allah and part for
someone else you have to do completely
for the sake of Allah subhana wa tala
only for him and no one else Allah does
not like anyone associating anything
with him that's very important so this
is a basic point that is
the the second point to be noted for our
deed to be acceptable is that our deed
should be based on the Shar it should be
in accordance to Allah and his
accordance to the teachings of the Quran
and teachings of our beloved Prophet mm
wasallam it's mentioned in s Muslim
number
three Hadith number
4267 we beloved Prophet Mall wasallam
said that if your deeds and actions are
not according to our way according to
the religion of Islam according to Quran
and S Hadith then that is
rejected that means for a deed to be
accepted it should be according to Quran
and and it's also mentioned in another
say Hadith of Abu
da volume number three Hadith number
495 our beloved Prophet malli wasallam
said that he told the people that follow
my example and the example of
Kash that's the rightly guided CIS so if
you follow them and cling to it with ey
teeth that means strongly follow it the
Sunnah of the Prophet my Sunnah the
prophet said that his Sunnah his way and
the way of the rash that is rightly
guided CIS so for a deed to be accepted
an should be only for Allah subhana tala
and be according to the Quan and Subhan
Allah for those answers now
alhamdulillah this is the part of the
show as we promis that if time
permitting we had time to uh receive
some of your questions relating to the
topic we would do so and we do have a
little bit of time so Dr Zakia why is it
that Ramadan specifically is put on its
own in terms of uh it being welcomed
what about other months like Hajj the
month of Hajj Etc the reason we Muslims
welcome the month of Ramadan all the
months in the year are good
alhamdulillah but the reason we
specifically welcome the month of
Ramadan because Ramadan is a month of
forgiveness it is a month where I
mentioned earlier our beloved Prophet
wasallam said that the doors of heaven
will be
opened the Gates of Hell will be closed
and the Devils will be chained so
because of this
reason this this month is welcome and
whatever deed we do it will be
multiplied 10 times the reward that we
get for every deed in this month is 10
times more because of this and whatever
we ask for forgiveness as our beloved
Prophet said that if we fast for the
full month of Ramadan with the true
intention and with proper Faith asking
reward from Allah subhana wa ta'ala all
our pass will be forgiven mentioned s
bukari number three book of fasting
Hadith number 1901 so because of this
purpose this month is welcomed so that
we look forward for our sins to be
forgiven and for our Deeds to be
multiplied a good deeds to be multiplied
that is the reason specifically we
Muslims we welcome this month of Ramadan
mallah